[Musique]
quand l'électricité partie on s'est bien
entendu un énorme bruit c'est très très
bruyants les maisons qui tombe dans le
four de tous on a perdu nos villages on
a perdu c'est des amis elle est enceinte
de cinq mois le temps d'un petit bébé a
nui à la vie
'sans l'être humain peut rien contre la
nature
ginette chavarie a attendu cinquante ans
avant de remettre les pieds à
saint-janvier n'est les revues personnes
en arrière le raconter sur le fait
qu'aujourd'hui il publie rien que rick
elle avait 18 ans le soir du drame
un peu avant 23 heures elle dormait au
sous sol mais j'entends massa puis ma
mère crier quant au montant au
dépêche-toi pose pas de questions au
même moment une scènes similaires se
déroulent un peu partout dans le village
de 1300 personnes
roland de la voix la fille du maire a
alors 23 ans un coup de téléphone alerte
sa maisonnée on veut trouver votre envie
de crier quand il ya des maisons qui
tombe des personnes avec à l'intérieur
des maisons ils criaient les maisons
toujours debout n'ont plus d'électricité
chantal arsenault ou n'avait que 8 ans à
l'époque moi je savais qu'il fallait
sauver
je voulais apporter mes petits vêtements
de petite fille comme ma mère m'avait
acheté pas longtemps à 20
robert bourgeois habitait dans une
maison un peu plus loin en amont et
souvenir de cette soirée de ses 13 ans
sont intactes j'ai vu tomber
l'autobus de la cage il tomber l'autre
tous que la femme surtout le site web de
loin les citoyens doivent évacuer le
village en catastrophe savais pas si ça
allait partir en avant toi même si tu
avances et l'on affirme annie arrêtent
une voiture qui dit dépêchez vous allez
vous-en les maisons soit près de prouver
la maison bourgeois est parti ce serait
mon frère
le lendemain trente et une personnes
sont portées disparues
la lumière du jour révèle l'ampleur du
drame qui s'est déroulé sous leurs yeux
des maisons sombre toujours dans une
épaisse couche d'argile
en même temps quand on est au vert la
radio puis avec mon ami là il nommait
toutes les personnes qui étaient décédés
l'horloge et pleure robert bourgeois n'a
aucune nouvelle de son frère gilles de
sa conjointe diane arsenault et de leur
petite fille annie deux ans diane était
la soeur de chantal arsenault je sais
pas de quelle façon qui sont décédés je
sais que c'est une des premières maisons
qui ont été engloutis dans doucement
vers un faux pas que je pense j'en parle
j'en ai des frissons là j'espère seniors
qui sont partis très rapidement
ginette chavarie l'a échappé belle cette
maison à gauche au bout de la rue
stanley 7 et celle de ses parents après
le sinistre
le gouvernement de robert bourassa a
ordonné le déménagement du village
aujourd'hui il ne reste presque plus
rien saint jean vianney la nature a
repris ses droits dans les rues
auparavant peuplées de jeunes familles
mais douze personnes n'ont jamais été
retrouvés 100 km h avait mal que je les
reçois cinq sont là
ressent les noms des victimes se
retrouvent dans un parc arvida on peut
aussi apercevoir les anciennes maisons
déménagé de saint-jean-vianney dans un
quartier résidentiel de l'arrondissement
de jonquière comme ici sur la rue du
buisson
john locke quelle ne fut pas la surprise
pour robert bourgeois de découvrir en
revenant dans le quartier que les
propriétaires actuels de son ancienne
maison sont eux aussi originaires de
saint janvier n'est l'espace d'une
rencontre les anciens résidents se
remémorent leur jeunesse dans ce petit
village où tout était encore à bâtir
mais où la nature en a décidé autrement
[Musique]